alors joeystarr c'est comme faire un
travail et la chauffer les pneus l'album
derniers mondiaux et star vous êtes un
petit peu souvent dans la quatrième
dimension on va vous faire une interview
quatrième dimension
je
yach khalfan qui dit que vous avez bougé
par un jingle milos pas vous le dire il
a raison serge alors quel pays de la
quatrième dimension choisiriez vous pour
vivre le pays où on travaille pas le
pays on vieillit pas où le pays on n'est
jamais malades
je m'appelle mazunga et on récolte quand
la ville que vous choisiriez dans la
quatrième dimension la ville où il n'y a
que vous celle où vous n'avez que des
amis ussel n'ya que des femmes
c'est toujours ça
il ya que mes amis dans la quatrième
dimension tout est possible vous en
profitez pour aller sur mars pour se
taper le crous ou pour faire avorter la
maman d'hitler piétiner la mère du caire
pendant qu'elle est enceinte
je suis myope comme ça je m'appelle
nique ta mère pour ces raisons là des
gens pareils comprendre le truc avant
l'offre
c'est pas terrible ce que j'aime bien
dans la quatrième dimension le temps est
différent vous en profitez pour vous
offrir un retour dans votre enfance
une fois par semaine pour faire des
escapades dans le futur ou pour vivre le
temps présent au maximum en l'étirant
joie suite
temps présent maximum en l'étirant d'un
quatrième dimension il ya un autre
calendrier vous choisissez le mois où
l'argent est gratuit le mois où les
joints tourner pendant 30 jours ou le
mois ou en bandes quatre semaines ce qui
fait déjà tiré et l'a doublé et pinto de
la journée non mais je voyage je suis
comme tout le monde ne va pas voir le
monde du quartier quoi ce quartier c'est
le méchant
non mais je vais vous laisser partir mon
petit la rigueur
colas